各位好 欢迎来到我们的如何阅读第二讲
它的名字叫做重建作者的逻辑
那为什么叫重建作者逻辑呢
因为上一节课我们刚刚帮着大家去解构了一下作者的逻辑
现在我们要完成下半部分
就是作为读者你应该做什么
就是道理我们都明白
但是我做不到 是吧
所以这个部分才是真正实操的这个部分
那么我想来想去还是觉得选择一篇文章
带着大家以例子的方式
以这种直观的方式
直接把整个流程给梳理下来
可能会达到事半功倍的效果
所以我们今天选了一个材料
叫做哲学冲动通向何方
它的一个节选只有四一而止
这个是这本书的导论的部分
当然我选一是选择哲学的话题
那么它的思辨程度比较高
第二是这本书
这本书叫做哲学是如何做出来的
这本书是一个通识类的这样一个小读本
那么难度呢
语言的难度呢
也不大
所以比较适合当例子
所以我们在今天呢
其实就是想给大家说一下
你看在这
我给的这四张图的最左边
实际上就是相对线性的这种文本
对吧
那么最右边的实际上很立体的这个过程
其实啊
我们今天就想完整的回溯一下
从这个四页的小文本是怎样抽象出
这样一组小小的命题
然后呢再把它们去分类
然后最后呢重构起来
这样一个全过程
当然我们今天这个课程可能会时间稍微长一些
毕竟我们要再完整的读四篇文章
所以大家跟住了
那我们来看一下
不是四篇文章四页文章
这个节选是这样的
这个一般来说呢
我们会这个上来之后啊
既然我们现在已经不再是以上帝视角
知道作者在想什么了
所以我们只能从这里面去提炼
去不断的总结
所以第一个点要点你记住了啊
就是每一段这个话
有的是废话
有的不是废话
那么对于不同人来说
对有的人来说是废话
对有的人来说不是废话
就像我现在说的这些
对有的同学就是废话
好那我们不啰嗦了啊
直接进入
什么意思呢
就是什么叫废话
上来
他会第一段
你读就行了
几乎所有人都曾在某些时刻
经历过某种冲动
你一定也一样
通常那会是一种感觉
一份惊奇或不安
突然闯入你的日常生活
他常常自己化为一个朦胧
但富有启发性的问题
时空会永恒不灭吗
若上帝不存在会怎样
或若存在会怎样
是否有人真正的自由
一件事情真的有对于错吗
有没有真绝对真理
其实啊
什么叫做废话啊
就是对于
真的平时有这种冲动的
经常性的有这种冲动
比如说我平时就经常会有这种冲动啊
天天去幻想啊
去去陷入到沉思中
对吧
讲这个终极三问是吧
我从我是谁
我从哪来
我到哪去啊
还有终极第四问啊
今天中午吃什么
诸如此类的这种非常抽象的问题
那么有的同学可能就没有过这样一些终极的想法
可能比较务实
所以这个文章的作者也是一样的
那么对于像我这样的跟他想法差不多一致
其实他说到经历某种冲动的时候
我就已经知道他下面要写什么了
我就已经完全明白后面的这些问题
对于很多人来说
说我没有经历过哪种冲突啊
你能给我举一个例子吗
那这些例子就是时光会永恒不灭
有的东西说啊我明白了
是是是我有过这种思考
有人说嗯我不知道你什么意思
直到最后呢才会发现
原来你说的是这种旋之又旋的问题
可能我两年前的某一天
真的会想到这一点
所以啊
这一段说完了之后啊
我们把它读完吧
他说这个某件艺术作品
我们从这开始啊
某件艺术作品真的就比其他的更好吗
当然还有人生的意义是什么
这类感觉就是亚里士多德在哲学
在说哲学起于惊奇时
心中所想的问题
无论多么难以言表
人理解事物时的不得其门而入
一个大问题还有待回答
这样的不安感正是那种冲动
将人引入哲学活动
其实你说完了之后
就是说白了
人会有大问题
且经常
因无法回答
不得其入
对吧
而陷入哲学
我就paraphrase了
我就给重述一遍用我的话来说
所以整个这一段
我画一下
它实际上关于的就是这一点
那我们来看一下
这其实就是一个简单的
就是我们为什么要把这东西用一句话给他
表述出来呢
我们为什么要这样去做呢
是因为我只有通过这样一种方式
我才能就是因为刚才我们说过
有的文章里面就是对很多同学来说所谓的废话
就是因为你这个废话
所谓的废话就是当它它有没有作用
它是有作用的
但是它的作用无非就是在诠释
我们右侧写出来的一个点
你只要能抓住作者想表达这种意思
这种诠释就可以忘掉了
说我得到了
我明白你要讲什么了就可以了
所以我们说把书读薄
就是这个意思
那我们继续
我们继续
他说少有人能突破这个临界点
原因很简单
人们不知道该如何突破它
一个人该如何思考这类问题
人能够思考这类问题吗
也许根本就不可能突破这个临界点
心智退缩了
人的思考亮亮强强
原地打转
乱作一团
结果实际错失
或者眼睁睁看实际错失
重要的问题
不知怎的就被抛诸脑后
其实到这儿有同学已经明白了
我太能感受这种感觉了
就是事一砸
我本来那些
我认其实挺重要的这些
时空问题
上帝的问题
对错的问题
绝对真理的问题
说明天再想吧
有空再想吧
我想这些干嘛呢
反正就是被搁置
被锯齿或者被压抑掉了
然而那种感觉却长久挥之不去
那是种沮丧的感觉
毕竟这都是重要的问题
应该得到重要的答案啊
要是有人知道
应该如何寻求答案该多好
所以大家你看
如果你就很多同学
其实读到这的时候
就已经对上一段所说的话
模模糊糊了啊
就感觉到
我上一段好像读到了一个很重要的东西
但实际上如果你
包括不一定是要写在纸上
只需要在头脑中有这样一个印象
说人是有大问题的
经常困惑
于是去思考
对吧
实际上呢
这一段
我们能说的第二段
其实就是在去
再去重述这样一件事
对吧
给你绘声绘色带起来
当然我们说阅读速度快的同学
也就电光火石之间两段读完了
我想这个并不困难
我只是把事情稍微慢了一点
突塌一点
毕竟我们有很多同学
其实从来没有接触这类的文本
我们来往下看
他说做哲学的人
不好意思写错了
做哲学的人除其身份之外
正是努力寻求这些答案的人
其实好多同学说明白了
这一段要干嘛呢
这一段说的其实就是哲学家
哲学是什么
哲学家的这个作用是什么
那有同学说我没看出来
那我们继续往下
他说做哲学的人的各项职责之一
就是要突破这种萌芽中的感觉
将这些朦胧而富有启发性的大问题
纳入理性活动的范围
将这些问题从心情带入到心智中
所以各位你看我这个在很多节课之前
在上一节课的时候
就跟各位说过
有一些概念的
你还是要关注一下
就是尽量把一个文文
不要把它看成是那种漫天弹悬
你还是要有一种
某定某一个概念去理解它
这样一种感觉
我说的也可能有玄幻楼
举一个例子
就是说你要能抓得住
把做哲学的各项职责
你要用一种非常清晰的语言
去表述出来什么职责
把大问题纳入理性范围
把问题从心情带入到心智中
是这样的一些
是这样的一个一个一个的锚点
就是我们对对对
什么是心情
什么是心智
对吧
心情就是感受
就是我们所说的感性的去看世界
世界是什么
你可能用各种各样的诗意的语言
去描述它
所谓心智呢
就是我来给你做一个
集体的分析
实际是什么
那么哲学家的一部分工作
就是把这类问题
转变为可供人思考的形式
然后思考它
所以我想像这种话
对我来说非常重要
为什么它非常重要
它是能够把整个这一段
给说清楚的一句话
什么是哲学
一句话就说清楚了
对于这样一项事业
哲学家必须兼顾兼具整体的策略
即一套方法
即具体的战术
即应用这套方法的技术
它有策略
它有方法
它有战术和它有技术
对吧
他们的确是这样做的
哲学是一种理性活动
拥有自己的策略和战术
自己的方法技术
简而言之
它是一门学科
所以哲学到底是什么学科
我们其实已经可以推断出来了
我们可以总结出来了
如果你不知道的话
你可以看我是怎么总结的
哲学是这样一本学科
哲学是什么什么的学科
那它是什么什么的学科呢
把大问题
转变为
供人思考的形式
并具备完整的自己的策略也好
战术也好
方法也好
技术也好的学科
就把它总结出来了
所以我们画一个
这样一个方块
这个方块实际上是可以转变过了
给他画一个更加看起来
那酷的方块
这个就是第三段他所说的话题
你看其实并不难
就是把你心里想的
把你读懂的这个东西
不一定要写出来
就是在头脑中把它呈现出来
为什么要这样做
三段读完了之后
大家就可以看到
我们如果看这两段的话
我们总结出两个
人会有大问题
经常也无法回答而陷入哲学思考
而哲学呢
就是把这种大问题转为
供人思考的
这样一个非常具体的
这一系列
这个方法的这种学科
所以你读完了之后
你这一总结说
这三段其实并不难
对吧
就是你头脑中有一个
非常清醒的一个意识
所以这三段其实内容就被你怎么了
被你压缩了
大量的解释 大量的去对读者友好的这种方式
这个策略也就慢慢的被你消化掉
书就越来越薄了
好 他继续说
他说哲学这门学科以上的最让人惊讶的特征是
就是它是在学院中被划分为
关于其他诸学科的多种多样的哲学
不知道各位能不能看清 放大一些
你会发现有如此如下科目的研究课程
科学哲学
艺术哲学
宗教哲学
数学
历史等等
各种哲学
对吧
涵盖了人类智性工作的全部范畴
好了
我们就知道哲学跟其他学科有交叉
对吧
这是我们暂时读到的
然后他说
因此哲学具有了一种二阶学科的性质
那各位其实你可以推断出来
一阶学科是什么
一阶学科就是刚才我们看到的那些科学艺术宗教历史
这叫一阶对吧
然后在某种意义上
它可以是关于科学家
艺术家
神学家
数学家
历史家
心理学家
法学家
语言学家
及他们的许多同行所从事的一阶学科活动的二阶学科
又重新帮你梳了一遍
梳了一遍
如果有人坚持用一句术语来描述哲学的主旨
那么它势必需要一个非常宽泛的主旨描述
诸如接近人的理性的认知的或概念性的活动之类
以此观止哲学作为一种活动
是将理性运用于自身的操作
是理性实践所做的理性研究
你不用管它说有多啰嗦多麻烦
其实大家已经明白了
对不对
好像啊
哲学是为了其他学科
就是二阶学科
为一阶学科
去提供某种
某种处理方法的
某种
反正我们形容不上来
对不对
做这也没有说的
特别特别的
这个完全完全清楚
对吧
反正就是
他们是不在一个维度上的一个话题
对吧
就是以这种方式来讲
最后一句
以这种方式来讲
哲学以及独特的方式
关乎一切所有的关乎
对吧
但我们能总结出来什么
我们从这儿其实能看得出来
就是哲学
我这样写
怎么画了个翻角形
删掉
哲学是二阶学科
其实在这儿
我们很多同学其实有一个天然的一种非常好的一个阅读习惯
我们在第三节课会想说
这个叫问题意识
什么叫问题意识
就是马上你会所谓主动阅读者
就是他马上就观察到一个点数
等一下
他是二阶学科
但他跟一阶学科的区别到底是什么
我们刚才实际上没看出来的
对不对
我们知道
就模模糊糊有一个印象
哲学跟神学数学等等
提供某种服务
我们知道他跟所有的学科有这个交界
他提供了某种
我貌似理解的一个东西
但是作者有没有详细的给你解释
其实并没有
就这种问题意识
其实对各位来说非常的重要
那我们在下一节课会详细的跟各位去讲
那我们继续往下看吧
他说以此观止
哲学实际上也关乎自身
哲学本身也是一种理性活动
因此也录入它自身的研究范围之类
其实就是哲学的哲学
对不对
这个我们能理解
而且确实存在关于哲学的哲学
叫做原哲学研究
比如说这是个好例子
你看这是好例子
什么是恰当的哲学问题
什么是适当的哲学方法论
本身就是两个恰当哲学问题的好例子
就是哲学的哲学
也从另一个角度表明了
为什么对哲学研究的主旨
给出一个恰当有效的精简描述
很困难甚至不可能
任何一个此类的描述
包括我刚才给出的
本身都在表达一种哲学的论题
立场或观点
其实大家能理解就是哲学的哲学
如果你哲学都没搞清楚的话
哲学哲学你可能更搞不清楚了
不管怎么样
哲学不仅是一个二级学科
它甚至是自己这个二级学科的二级学科
我姑且把这个事写成包括自身
他包括自己
他也为自己提供
但是仍然我们那个问题就是
二阶和一阶到底什么关系
我们仍然是不知道的
所以继续往下读
他说做哲学的人在这儿拿
做哲学的人倾向于提出这类二阶问题
从中人们看到哲学冲动在起作用
我们可以将这类问题分为两类
算是一种有意的
它们是关于意义的问题
和关于理由
关于正当理由
成立理由的问题
我想到这儿
大家就明白了
二阶问题实际上给出了一个定义
什么是二阶问题
什么是二阶学科
或者二阶
二阶学科就回答二阶问题的这些学科
对不对
关于意义
和关于正当理由
这种学科啊
这是我们读出来的
好
那而明显不在此分类的是关于真假的问题
各种做一阶学科的人会提出各种各样有趣的断言或主张
哎
大家看到了一阶学科是关于什么的
关于真假的这种断言或主张
其实所谓断言就是说
我声称一件事情
然后它或为真或为假
对不对
好像大家越来越明白了
如果你不明白的话
这就是所谓
比如我看到例如的时候
我就觉得它是废话
但是有同学如果没想明白
这个例如就帮了很大的忙
你看
例如一位物理学家可能会说
气体由分子组成
或所有物质对象都由原子组成
你就明白这个就是断言
这就是一个关于真假的问题
气体由分子组成
它或为真或为假
对吧
它就是一个assertion
这是一个断言
一位艺术评论家又给你举一个例子
可能会主张米开朗基罗的大卫像
与他的圣母莲子相相比
是更为逼真的作品
也可以判断
对吧
一位神学家可能会断言上帝是仁慈
一位历史学家可能会说
引发二人前代言主要是经济
一位语言学家会说
人类语言能力只能假定
由内生的语言能力基因传递
否则无法解释
你看都是可以判断的
对不对
诸如此类
所以你看这一段
就是所谓的废话
但什么是对有的人来说呢
刚看到例如两个字的时候
就觉得他是废话
有的人是直到看完了之后
才会觉得曾经他不是废话
现在他完成了他的使命
我明白什么是断言
什么是关于真假的问题了
那相反的不问这些问题的
就是什么呀
不问这些问题的
其实就是哲学上问的那个问题
就是关于意义和正当理由的
所以你读完这段之后
你明白了什么叫做一届学科
他们问的问题
什么是科学家问的问题
什么是心理学家问的问题
对不对
这种有趣的一届断言
实际是对是做
做哲学的人通常无意追问
如果强迫他们关注
他们或以此为有婉拒
他们并不像一届研究者那样
具备判断此类断言
真假所需的专门知识
就是学家说我也不知道
对吧
你问我分子的问题我不知道
但他们会坚持有些问题
需要先行解决
这些工作才是他们
关心的对吧
也就是说当你读到此为止
你明白了一个道理
说一阶学科真假
我明白了
但二阶关于意义和正当理由
我仍然不知道什么
什么样的问题是关于意义
和关于正当理由的
所以我们才去读下面一段
他说哲学家在实践中
始终关心的一类问题是
理解有趣的一阶断言
说一件艺术作品
如果你不明白什么叫理解的话
他举了一个说
一件艺术作品比另一件完成度更高
是什么意思
什么又是潜在原因
大家明白
这个道理就是
不是说他问潜在原因是什么
而是潜在原因这个词是啥意思
那么哲学家素来不情愿以表面价值看待此类断言
并非因为他们本性比别人更爱怀疑
而是因为他们通常会私立此类断言
表面价值究竟是什么
比如说如果你看
就是所有的这一些话你看不懂
都可以通过比如说来看懂
气体由分子组成这句话
看起来已经是相当直截了当的一个断言了
那哲学家问的问题是什么呢
可是气体由分子组成
与T自由横挡和T柱组成
是相同的组成方式吗
所以说科学家问的问题是
气体是由分子组成的吗
建筑学家或者是一个工匠问的问题
是梯子是由这两个组成的吗
那哲学家问的问题是
这两种组成方式
它本质上它的逻辑上是一致的吗
所以这是哲学家问的问题
与拼图与小块组成是相同的吗
与森林与树木组成相同的
每一个具体的这个问题
森林由树木
是由树木组成的
这是一个一介学科的问题
或者是断言
那么他们彼此之间的
这个背后的这种逻辑
背后的这种价值
是诸学家问的问题
与句子与词组成相同吗
与蛋糕与面粉
鸡蛋糖
奶油
牛奶组成相同吗
一个看得见
有颜色的东西
比如一把椅子
是如何全部有比原
比如原子这种看不见
单个原子
有肯定没有颜色的东西组成的呢
哲学家的问题
所以我们现在看出来了
整个这一段
其实都是关于什么叫做
什么叫做意义
什么叫做正当理由的
那我们把它给它标注出来
这是关于正当理由的
那你看这一些解释
都是在关于一解学科的
好吧
文章开始不断的去整合了
那其实读到这的时候
我们就发现
咱们看右侧的咱们这个所谓笔记
其实就是大家头脑中
你在平时阅读的时候
有的人阅读是不记笔记的
没关系
你在头脑中有这个就可以了
哲学是什么
哲学就是一种把大问题转为
供人思考形式具备策略战术方法
和这个技术的这样一门学科
那它具体是什么学科呢
它是一个二届学科
那二届学科跟一届学科什么区别呢
二节学科是关于意义
关于正当理由的
一节学科是关于真真假的
这种断言和主张的
那么什么是真
什么样的问题
到底什么是关于真假
到底什么是关于意义的
于是我们看到了
这给你举了一个例子
所以我们读到这儿了
你看过半了
两页文章
其实就有这一串又一串
这一点又一点
他们联系在了一起
那么接下来他说再比如
再比如啊
我们其实就已经明白了
他其实还是要继续解释
对不对
我们很能清楚的理解
对父母或法官来说什么叫仁慈
但神学家所示上帝的人慈
与我们日常所说的仁慈是一样的吗
别忘了上帝人慈显然被认为是以疾病
干旱 饥荒 战争 地震 飓风 龙颠风 台风存在
以及万般人类疾病是相容的
而他显然允许这些灾祸
毫无分别的降临
在无辜的人有罪人身上
这很难符合我们通常对一位仁慈的人的要求
再比如哲学家会问
我们把语言能力由基因传递
说成如眼睛颜色那样
通过基因传递的某种东西
对此我们是否有清晰的概念呢
如果我们把基本的哲学生能看作是
表达我们的一种需求
一种让世界有意义
让我们身处其中有意义的需求
那我们能注意到
从事各种各样一节学科的人
也时常对我们这个世界
即我们在其中的位置
做出许多有趣刺激
但经常是费解和异常的表述
而哲学的应用则集中于理解
即澄清这些从事一阶学科人的表述
大家别忘了
这还有一个词叫做理解
我们刚才说什么
哲学家在实践中始终关心的一类问题
是理解这类有趣的一阶断言
我们大体上可以把这一段作为什么呀
作为对刚才所描述的这一个段落
进一步的一个补充
就是哲学所谓的意义正当理由到底是什么
又加了一段
生怕你不理解
好
那我们来看一下
既然是理解
其次
哲学家会在实践中追问从事一阶学科的人
凭什么做出他们实际所各种有趣的断言
那大家注意
你要明白这个其次
它跟的是谁
各位可能有同学已经有印象了
他说的是其实在哪呢
在这个地方
就是哲学家在实践中关心的一类问题
是理解这些断言
对吧
让你所谓理解就是刨根根底的
去问你到底你的这些断言
它到底实际意义是什么
对不对
另外一个
他说你凭什么给出这个断言
凭什么你说分子
空气是有分子
你是怎么得出这个结论的
对吧
凭什么你说上帝是一个仁慈的人
仁慈的这样一个存在
你是怎么给出这个结论的
所以大家就可以看到
所谓二阶学科
我们就在这可以给二阶学科往下啊
再写一个点
二阶就是哲学
问的问题
关心什么呢
理解
第一理解
一届学科
然后他用了两段左右
来说清楚这句话
来说清楚什么是理解
然后呢
我们在这个地方
他说二届学科
尤其是哲学
他关心
二
一阶学科
凭什么
就是这个不是我们赌气的那个凭什么
而是一个真正就是by what
by what standard
你凭什么样的
你凭借什么
你凭借什么标准
做出他们实际的这种断言
也就是说从根本上追问他们这些断言提供
或能够提供的知识
无论明确与否
在实验室中各种物质对象及仪器
他们可观察的总体行为
是如何证明了物理学家那些
对不可观测威力或作用力的断言呢
这个应该学理工科同学应该很明白
对不对
物理学等等这种自然科学
是一个高度依赖经验和观察的
这样一些学科
对吧
是一个经验主义的学科
它是靠归纳
主要是靠归纳来去验证某一个假说的
那么有一些东西
有一些物理理论不可观测
对吧
那么你的这个观测的这个实验过程
是怎么能去论证不可观测的这个
这个假说或者是断言呢
这个中间的这种检查
就是我们说假设你的所有的步骤都是对的
但是这个中间的逻辑
链是哲学家他们关心的事情
对吧
再举一个例子
审美的诸种判断可以在主体间有效吗
一或者他必然只能是个人品味的表达
对于特定的神学主张
是否需要一种特殊的宗教体验
提供知识
是否存在这样一种体验
是否可能存在这样一种体验
你看他的这个问题
跨各种各样的学科
对吧
人们
那也就是说我们这一段
其实啊
是能够总结出
哲学关心的是
一届学科来凭什么
做出这样一些理论
好
人们说
最常认为的哲学性问题
传统的哲学研究领域
包含的典型事物
就是上述问题的彻底
普遍化形式
总结了
对吧
哲学家通常不是对这个
或那个具体审美标准基础
做追问
而是会问审美判断
是否普遍具备客观成立理由
是否关乎价值审美道德
是否关乎价值审美或道德判断
都有能成的客观的成立理由
价值判断
实时判断间
隐行对立
哲学家也不倾向于认为是理所当然
各位
其实你到这儿能这儿看懂的话
可能需要一定的
比如说美学的基础
对吧
需要一些价值论的基础
但我相信到这儿
你的大的途径已经构建起来了
并不需要有文嚼字的说
我一定要明白什么是价值判断
什么是试试判断
什么叫做银行对立
有同学在这个地方说
我判断不出来
说我如果这读不懂的话
我不知道会不会影响我对全文的理解
但其实大家观察到
如果我们持续性的对本文的逻辑进行一个一定的追踪的话
我们并不难做出这样的判断说
这一块我理解到多少程度
我才能对全文有所理解
好吧
那么这一区分是否有意义的话出
如果可以又怎样归类
这都有待探究
再有对任何从观察到的事物
都观察不到事物的推论
这些家会追问起合理性
无论推论出事物理学家
力和威力
寻常人的想法和欲望还是明早太阳
当然还有
其实就是什么呀
就哲学家关心的问题特别多
除了去理解一阶学科和除了去问凭什么
他有各种各样的
再有
还有
其实就是一堆又一堆的哲学家关心的问题
换句话讲
这一边就是
哲学
括号二阶学科
关心很多很广泛的问题
我们把它画下来
好
所以你看这一段其实就是在解释
抽象的讲哲学的目标
就是在于去理解最最广义的事物
是如何最最广义的联系在一起的
那么我们再往下
他说无论具体的方法论是什么
哲学的实践都是以一阶事实保持着一定距离进行的
这与具有一阶学科特性的活动不同
看出总结的意思了
对吧
由此而论也与我们在日常实践世界中的事物不同
因此哲学是一种相当纯粹与抽象的实践
在这个意义上说哲学全然不是对事实的研究
哲学不是对事实研究
那是对什么的研究呢
而是研究我们之所以能够探索这些事实的方法
就是我不管你探索什么
那么我现在想的是你探索这个东西用什么样的方法
好吧
研究我们能够断定这些事实所依据的合理基础或理由
大家马上就看到了
其实它是关于正当理由的
对不对
二届学科的基本特点正当理由而不是真假的问题
以及我们用来表达这些事物的概念
举一个例子
已故的同事福尔克曾这样说
普通人问时间是几点钟
而哲学家问时间是什么
好
其实就是什么呀
叫哲学
总结哲学是什么
以及不是什么
不是对事实的研究
而是对能够探索这个事实方法
断定这些事实所依据的
基础这个理由
表达这些实施的概念
他研究的是这些东西
而不是实施本身
那认识到这一点
我们便可对哲学实践中
众多古怪疑难之处进行解释
最后一段了
比如哲学方法表面上的
灰色难懂且任意而为
比如哲学经常令人沮丧的
缺乏固定方向
缺乏广为接受的具体成果
来体现进步之感
还有更为普遍的不真实感
和分裂的气氛
这正是让非哲学人士
感受到最鲜明的哲学学科的特点
半自嘲对吧
半自嘲
所有的这些现象的根源来自于一个事实
哲学家从不以直接的方式思考这个问题
他们思考的恰恰是思考这个世界
他们思考的是思考这个世界
就是你如何思考这个世界
对吧
如果取得了什么成果
它形式不同于新现实
而是新的明晰性
阐明已有的事实是什么
或不是什么
探讨这些既有事实
以何种方式具有合理性
他不关心
没被发现的时候
他已经发现
他在夯使各种各样
其他的一介学科
做出来的各种各样的
发现和断言
他底下的这种根基
所以我们用了很长时间
把整个这一篇文章给顺了下来
就是它是一个
我把这个画的方一点
好
这其实就是一个我们把它
放大
大家就能看明白了
其实这个文章
从上到下是以这样一种思路
我们如果不看左侧
只看右侧的话
就变成了人们会经常有种冲动
标题叫做哲学冲动影像导向何方
对不对
人们会有大问题
那么哲学就是在解决这种大问题的
那么哲学是怎么解决这种大问题的呢
因为它是一个二届学科
那什么是二届学科呢
二届学科是关于意义
关于正当理由的
那一届学科是什么呢
它是关于真假断言主张的
好
如果你明白了这一点的话
下面都可以不用看了
对不对
这篇文章你就明白了
但是后面都在给你解释
那二届学科到底是什么
它是关于理解一届学科的
它是关于一届凭什么是这样去做的
关于很多很广泛的问题
唯独不关心什么
事实的问题
它只关心事实探究事实这种方法
所以其实阅读没这么难
就是很简单
很简单这样去把它构建起来
但是我相信大家很好奇的就是
在这种行进的这个过程中
你想让我
比如说能不能给在座的各位
呈现出我整个头脑中
是什么样子的
因为我以前这样去讲
大家说老师你好秀
对吧
你确实把这篇文章给读完了
但是我自己试一下
发现是不行的
就跟很多同学玩游戏
看主播打这个带节奏一样
你发现操作很秀
我自己一玩
就死得很惨
那我就想了一个办法
是这样的
我把刚才的这个文本呢
和我们总结出来的东西
其实就给它列在这个地方
你会发现每一段
或者每某几
有个比较相似的段落
我就总结成一句话了
对吧
很多同学啊
在去照猫画虎的时候
你无非就是把啊
这文章这样去做了
做完了之后呢
放成右边的这种形式啊
这右边这种形式
就是这个简单的一个笔记
这样罗列出来
这样做没有问题
它是你必要的一步
对吧
如果你要想刻意去训练的话
它是必要一步
它练了什么呢
它就练了你对每一个段落
就是每一个小的单位的这样一种总结能力
这是基本功
很重要
你就把这个东西给总结成一句话了
这很重要
但它不够
同时在你头脑中发生的
其实还有下面的这个部分
是什么部分呢
就是我们说过
你要重建作者的这种立体的逻辑
线性的文本怎么去重建立体的逻辑
你要就是在这个
当然我希望啊
我现在给大家展示的
并不是说我写出来的东西
而是我头脑中的
大概的这样一种印象
就是我在读书的时候
可能会去给他
以在头脑中以假想的颜色的这种方式
标明哪一个才是真正的大的主题
大的命题
哪一些才是往下中小的命题
所以在这里面
我其实就把线性的文本
比如说读完前几段之后
我大体上就把这个归类了
前几段读完了之后
说有回答大问题的冲动
无法得到回答
这个大家有印象
对吧
哲学是把这类问题转成个思考的形式
对
我有印象
哲学对其他学科以及自身而言
是二阶学科
在这你可能就发挥了很多很多自己的这种总结
就什么是最重要
你把它放在一起的话
你会发现哲学
它其实就讲哲学是什么
哲学家是什么
具体问了什么样的问题
具体怎么引导我读到这的
我其实早已经想不起来了
我想起来就是哲学
最后定义为被作者定义为
很重要的一个点
就是将大问题转成可思考形式的二阶学科
对吧
那我还清楚的记得
他用了很大篇幅给你去讲
二阶学科和一阶学科
有什么区别
用各种各样的例子
对不对
那么有种区别
二阶学科是关于意义与正当理由的
在这个部分
一阶学科是关于真假的
在另外一个部分
对吧
那么大家是否还记得
其实你会发现
他用了相当长的一个篇幅
告诉你
二阶学科实际上
什么叫做意义
什么叫做正当理由
他俩到底什么关系
其实二届学科是理解一届学科的
什么叫理解一届学科
对吧
在文章中给了你答断答断的论述
追问凭什么
对吧
你是用什么样的方法
比如物理学
你怎么能用这种靠观察的这种实验方法
去得出一个不可观测的这种微粒子的这样一个
这样一个状况
这样一个结论呢
我想检验一下你整个的逻辑链条是什么
以及还有一段是哲学有什么
他们关心这关心那关心的一大堆一大堆的东西
都是在协调他们的关系
到后面呢
你会发现他其实在最后的时候明确的表达
哲学就是说白了就是关于明晰性的研究
他只不过花了两段告诉你
他所谓的明晰不是对事实的研究
它是对探究事实方法的研究
和判定事实合理基础研究
当然还有其他的东西
我就没有写在这个地方
所以我们最后
给大家一张图
你就能看得出来左侧的
如果你仅仅是罗列的话
没有太大的问题
因为很多同学在头脑中
罗列罗列
他有一种自发的冲突
就说我开始自由的去组建了
但关键是
有同学可能没有这个意识
它简简单单就尤其是那种特别依赖
这个恭恭整整笔记的那一位同学
更是因为你记你把它认认真真的写下来
一笔一花写下来的话
必然会影响你的阅读速度和你的这种顺畅感
对吧
当然我也不是说去认为记笔记不好
只是说如果你要是把阅读速度放慢的话
那么你就应该主动的去思考架构
这个逻辑的这样一种问题了
好
那这儿红色的
如果全是这个线
把线性的大文本
变成了线性的小文本的话
那无非呢
就是练了一下自己的总结和归纳能力
我想如果大家想要去真的构建起
右侧的这种框架的话
那么左侧的在读的这个过程中
就不断的去想上一段和下一段
上一段下一段
下一段和前几段等等之间的
这种逻辑关系
这才是非常重要的
你会发现线性的文本和立体的逻辑
它其实不太一样
对吧
位置关系都是不太一样的
这个过程其实非常的困难
那么为什么
当然我现在把这个事情给大家讲
它是什么样子
对不对
就是整个线性文本怎么去重构
它这个全过程是什么样子的
但是我需要讲清楚另外两个关键的问题
就是他为什么这么我要讲这个东西
为什么这个东西我认为很重要
以及你如何才能够训练出来
大家也明白这一步很简单
任何人都能做到
但是这一步就特别困难
对吧
我可能轻描淡写就过去了
所以我要讲清楚如何你才能到第二步
第三步第四步
对吧
好
为什么重要
第一个问题
当我们根本连总结归纳的意识都没有
如果第一步你都不在头脑中进行的话
那么就会出现下面的这种阅读问题
读不懂
碎片化
读过就忘
恐惧阅读
因为你读到的东西真的就是碎的
对吧
连总结都没有
这书不仅没读薄
还能被歪曲
歪曲之后加上自己的脑补
加上各种各样的所谓价值观的灌输
你就不知道理解是什么样子了
对吧
可能跟元首都没有什么关系了
但是如果你简紧限于总结的话
就光看这张图
我都没有什么
我已经没有什么印象了
而且我不想看这些东西
对吧
就变成了死经被
其实就是我们高中那一套
花重点
然后考试题考第一点第二点第三点
其实你真的理解
为什么
他们彼此之间什么关系了吗
张一张之间有什么关系
历史之间之间有什么关系
不一定
对吧
所以这种人到这一步之后
他也不是读不懂
也不是读过就忘
但是他没有办法重组他读过的东西
他忘不了
或者是没有那么容易忘
但他可能就会出现什么
大段大段的引用
就是当跟别人聊的时候
他不可能从某一个某一本书里面抽离出一个特别抽象的东西
但是特别普世的东西去做他的遍体
而是掉出道
就是他读到的这个书的思考范畴仅限于这本书
仅限于这个学科
仅限于这个话题
他无法完成学习从某一个学科某一个领域
像另一个学科另一个领域的这样一种迁移的过程
而且这种人一般是没有办法去提出自己批判性见解的
就是他找不到漏洞
这种方式怎么找到漏洞
对不对
所以这种人很容易盲从盲信
而如果你有意识的去进行架构的话
但是最终没有成功的把它转成一个立体的这样一个模型
比如说你出现这一点
你明白这一块说主题
对吧
你明白它大体上分为二阶和一阶
但是彼此之间那种关系还是没建立起来的话
你可能具备不完整的这种观念
也比较成系统
但是你
而且你也能意识到它可能潜在有一些漏洞
但是你不知道具体在哪个地方
对吧
一吸想脑子就烂了
一气小脑子乱
就是以为自己懂
但实际上还是差点火候
而直到最后这一步的时候
你才能够用自己的语言去重述或总结
什么叫重述或总结
大家可能很多人写过学术综述
对不对
也有很多人说
在读书的时候
你写书评
写读书报告
其实都是
有同学说
我除了能够抓几个重点
能引几个摘要
我怎么写读书报告
我怎么写书评
我不知道
其实写书评
写读书报告
根本不是
写书评那些人是这样的
就是看了原文在这个部分
然后这句话我觉得挺有感悟的
我把它抄下来
这句话有感悟我把它抄下来
然后我发表自己的看法
这是很多大学生他去写读书报告和书评的这种方式
但实际上就这本书写什么东西
你要第一步你先重述整个文章
就是你不看这些东西了
这些东西都不看了
因为你总结出来了
对吧
都不看了
那你看什么呢
你把这个逻辑给他用自己语言顺下来
也就是此时你根本不参考
或者已经忘记了作者到底怎么说的
但是他整个这个逻辑你是明白
所以你用作者的角度再给他重述一遍
重述的这个过程中突然间发现某个地方有漏洞
某个地方有作者没有说清楚的地方
于是你在这个地方予以你的评论
所以你就先综合一下
然后你再分析一下
这样一个过程
它就能变成你自己知识与思考的这一部分
包括人们到这个阶段的时候
你可能注意的根本就不再是你一个一个矿了
那一个一个矿早就内化了
对不对
你在乎的是一条一条的中间这条线
不是这个框了
不是这个文本框了
那这样的话
这种人读书才就真正的把这个书给消化掉
他这个书才算读懂了
他所谓的这种人就是什么
就是什么神童啊
过目不忘啊等等
他说的都是这种表面的现象
因为这个人他完全吸收了这个书的这种精髓
而那些曾经帮助他理解这个精髓的那些所谓的废话
早已经被他忘掉了
好吧
就是第二个
你为什么这么重要
是吧
同学听了很心动
说老师这四个步骤
我怎么去完成
你的训练具体如下
就是前提条件
你要保障
阅读量要有保障
一定要是大量阅读
第二
选择的文本要超
什么叫阅读量要有保障
给大家两个说明
第一
选择的文本要超出自己知识储备
别超太多
超太多的话
就完全看不懂了
你连总结都总结不出来
对吧
那就没意义了
跳出舒适区一点点
有点挑战性
让自己学点新东西
因为如果是旧的东西的话
对吧
如果是旧的东西的话
你觉得这我都知道了
你很容易把自己先前的那种经验
那种认识给带进来
第二是擅长
你要不然就选择本领域的
对吧
要不然选择什么呢
擅长领域中
你要不然选择擅长领域中
更深度一点的
就什么叫挑战性
就是自己
比如说我是学历史学的
我可能会去读
我比较擅长欧洲史
然后可能会更加去深入的去
比如欧洲某国的
某一个段时间的经济史
对吧
更有深度的
里面带了一些史论的
这些东西
或者与擅长领域相关性领域
比如说我在读大学的时候
会更多的去接触社会学
去接触法学
法哲学等等
这些东西
与历史学直接相关的这种领域
这是前提条件
你的阅读量要保障
因为我们要不断的去试错
没有任何一个人在去读书的时候
在最开始都是说我要掌握一套方法
我第一本书就要完全消化掉
这不可能
跟各位说不可能
但很多人其实就倒在这个地方
说我昨天学的这个阅读课
我怎么今天就不好使了呢
是这个东西得真的得靠阅读量
有保证
那如果你会发现你真的想要得到一个
说我这一辈子
凡是这种我今天学了明天不见效的东西
我都不愿意学
是吧
如果你真的是这种人的话
也可以
问题也不大
就是你要一步步来
你先给自己一个短期的一个小目标
一个小的功力
能够见效的这样一个东西
就是先从归纳小体积文文开始
说白了
就你这一步你能做到
先来这一步
这个简单
一段一句话
其实就是什么
比如说你可以给每个段落起个小标题
随便起
对吧
因为你的目的不是说这标题对还是不对
你的目的是能够帮助你
把这个文章不走丢不落的往下去走
往下走下去
读下去
那么最关键的一个训练
其实并没有在这些课说
它叫做什么
叫做问出关键的问题
你会发现我在这个课程引导的过程中
其实在编读的时候有很多内心的读白
这些读白里面有好多都是什么
都是问题
一个自问自答的一个问题
有很多我的自问并没有自答
而是作者他下一段其实就说到了
那这种问题是怎么问出来的
这是我们下一节课要讲的内容
好了
那我们总结一下
这一节课呢
我们其实上一节课
我们用两次课的这个时间
给各位去完整的构建了一个
作者去解构一件东西
读者重构一件东西的一个过程
那这里面有一个缺失的一个环节
就是我们下一节课一个重点
就真的要完成读者重构的这个过程
真的杀手锏
就是问出一个特别关键关键关键的问题
从而才能引导你完成这几步
在头脑中的这样一个进化
从一个文本
然后最后真的能够变成了一个
自己能看得懂的
能记得住的
能表述得出的这样一个立体的逻辑
今天就到这里
谢谢各位